hello and welcome my name is dave today
we're going to build a to do web app
and we're going to use html css actually
sas
that compiles to css and then javascript
for the functionality
and we want our web app to be mobile
first and responsive
so of course designed for mobile phones
but then
also ready to scale up for tablet size
viewports
and then larger widescreen computer
monitors or possibly even
tvs and then we want our web app to be
accessible and by accessible i mean
accessible with a keyboard using the tab
index and the enter key
or also using a screen reader and then
we want to use persistent
data and that means we can close out of
our web app come back a week later
reopen the browser load up our web app
and our to-do list will still be there
with all the items we had on it
let's get started
i would like to thank free code camp for
sharing my video
and bo quincy and everyone involved in
making free code camp such a great
resource
a quick note about me i'm the father of
some great kids and some have autism
please check out my youtube channel and
you can connect with me
on twitter linkedin and reddit okay
we're starting our project with a blank
slate you can see over here i have a
folder named to do underscore list i've
got vs code
open and we should start with the html
that
is the foundation and the framework for
anything else we might do we'll start
with
a file called index.html
and in this file we'll first use an
image shortcut just type the exclamation
mark and you can see
emmett abbreviation i should say right
here
we'll choose that and it puts in a basic
page outline
i'm going to hit control z
i'm sorry alt z and that will wrap this
line that we couldn't see here before so
now you can see line
5 is just a little deeper and that's
because i'm wrapping the line that it
put in here
so now we'll put in some of our own
custom information
we need all of these lines especially
this viewport line that will help make
our
project responsive and we will later on
we'll put in
a style sheet line a script tag
for our javascript and that sort of
thing right now we'll just change the
title from document to
to-do list save that
and we've basically got our basic head
section
right now so now we need to go ahead and
put some things
in the body and i like to use semantic
elements when possible
we'll start with a main element of
course this also helps our accessibility
it's a great habit to have instead of
just using divs
and now our project as you can see the
finished project over here to the right
is really
broken down into two sections we've got
the area where we add
a new to-do list entry and then we have
the area that actually contains the list
and that's how we're going to break this
out is into two sections
and so we'll put in section elements
there's our first section and this is
going to be the new item entry so let's
give it a class
that says exactly that
having trouble typing again new item
entry and now that we've got our section
what this section is really going to
hold is a form
you can see this is an input it's a text
input
and this is a button which is a submit
button
and that's basically what's inside this
new item entry so let's
start with the form and we'll give it an
id of
item entry form
now inside the form we want to have a
label for the input
again this will help with accessibility
we'll call this label well it's four new
items we'll actually call the input new
item
and in the label we'll put enter a new
to do item well we don't even need the
period there we go
and now it's time for the input
and as i said it will be called new item
so in the label the for attribute
names the id of the input attribute
and this will be a text input so we'll
put type text
let's cap the size at
40 characters and we'll set
auto complete to off you may want it on
on yours of course that's when it gives
a list of suggestions or things you have
previously typed underneath
that's always kind of annoying to me so
i'm just going to turn it off
a placeholder and this is the text like
you see
add item that is the actual place holder
that goes
inside the text input of course i need
to put an
equals there add item
and then a tab index and this makes sure
it is keyboard accessible it is part of
the keyboard
index when you tab through the items so
we definitely want this input to be part
of that
put a tab index of zero oh and then we
can just slash
close because that doesn't have a
closing tag for the input it's just a
slash and then close out the element
okay what would go after that the button
and it is just a button element let's
give it an ad
id of
add item
yeah that makes sense add item class
let's just create a button class
because we're going to have another
button as you can see later for the
clear as well
the title attribute of this should be
add
new item and title is
what when you mouse over text will pop
up and show now i can't show you that in
when the dev tools are open because i
just get this kind of zero and it
doesn't do it but if i were to close
devtools and mouse over you would see
the title there
that's add new item i'm going to give
this button an
aria label this is part of the
accessibility
that we want to create for this web app
and here i'll put add new
item to list now why did i do that
well there is no text on the button it's
just a plus symbol
and that's not really descriptive for
anyone that is using a screen reader so
this aria label will help out with that
and let's also give this a tab index of
zero
and we'll close that and now a button as
you can see
does have a closing tag as well
we're just going to put the plus symbol
in here that's what you actually see
on the button so now we've got our form
it's got a label
an input and a button element and that's
the first section so i'll save that now
let's create the next section
and this section is for the container
that has the list
so we'll give this an i let's give this
a class
equal to list container
now inside this section we are going to
create some divs
at this point the first one
div with a class equal to
list title
and this will be this area here that has
the title
and it has the button it's just the top
of the list
so inside this we will put the title
and give that an h1 and you really only
want one h1 per page and this will be
the one for this page or
for this app
and now we'll also put a button here and
this will be the clear button
so this button is going to have an id
equal to
clear items
the class just like the other button we
created will be class
i mean sorry will be button
totally get that turned around the title
is going to be equal to
clear the list remember that's what pops
up when you mouse over the button
and let's also give this an aria label
because just saying clear
it gives a hint an indication of what
the button does but it's not as
descriptive as we could be
so we'll say aria label and remember
this is what a screen reader would read
remove all items from
the list that seems good oh and then a
tab
index again because this button also
needs to be part
of the tab order of the page
and we'll close that and of course a
button has a closing
element as well or closing tag for the
element
and we'll put clear in as the text for
the button like you see up here
go ahead and save that now
that should pretty much be it for that
div
but underneath the div we have a
horizontal rule this line you see so
we can create that with just the
horizontal rule element
and close it out at the same time it
doesn't have its own closing tag so just
like that
input element it just has a slash at the
end of the element
okay now our next div and this is for
the list
itself so create a div
and give it an id equal to list
items now really that's all we're going
to need
in our page the rest is dynamically
created when we
add an item it adds it to the list and
that will be created with javascript
but when we style the page it will be
helpful to see an item or two
in there before we start working with
the javascript so
you kind of want to plan ahead and know
what you want to create with your
javascript don't just
wing it so inside of here we'll put a
couple of items that
later on we can remove and each item
will be created with a div
we'll give each item a class
of as you might expect item
and then inside each div will be an
input
as you can see the check box and then
a label for that check box and by using
these
elements that are built into html that
once again helps us with our
accessibility we're not creating some
new text node or something like that
or just some div that we have to make
accessible later a label
is already associated with the check box
in html
so screen readers will respond to this
by just using a check box and a label so
we'll put an
oops an input element
and this type of input is a check box
and then each list item in our to-do
list will have an
id number so here we'll just id of one
remember we're just specking this out
later on we'll remove these
and they'll be part of the tab order of
the web app so
we'll give that a tab index of zero also
so it's included in the tab order
now this input needs a label and it will
be
for whatever id
number the to do item has so that in
this instance it will be four
id of one and then we just say whatever
we want to say and here is eat we've got
eat sleep code so
there we go there's an example item
let's just copy this
and put in at least one more so we'll
say
two two
and sleep other than that it's the same
and there we have finished the html for
the project
and remember these items are just here
for now we will remove them
and they will be generated with
javascript but we're putting these in
because
we want to style this next and we'll see
what we get
when we start styling the page okay
let's get started styling
our html you can see we have what the
finished product should look like here
and we have the html we created here and
i have started the live
server you can do that by clicking right
on your
html and use open with live server if
you don't have live server already in vs
code
go to the icon over here for extensions
type in live server
and here it is go ahead and install live
server and then you'll be able to do the
same thing you want to run
a local server and it makes it really
easy to do with live server
so you get the live server extension
right click
choose open with live server which i've
already done
and in this other tab here's our html
doesn't look quite as good as the
finished product yet but it
is the same html so we need to go ahead
and style that html
let's look at the file tree here and all
we have is our index.html file
i want to add a folder i'm going to call
this folder sas
and now you see i have a sass folder and
we'll include
sas files in here actually they'll be
files that end in the extension
scss because that's the style of sas i'm
going to use
now sas is very much like css3
but it gives us a few other advantages
to go along with that
so the first file we'll create in this
sas folder
is going to be style.scss
and now that we have a sas file as well
we need to add another extension and one
that will look at our sas
and we'll compile it to css as we create
it
so once again come to the extension icon
over here
and instead of live server type in live
sas and we're looking for live sas
compiler
you can see it's my third result here
i'll click on that
install live sas compiler and that's
exactly what this will do it will take
your sas
files it will merge them because we are
going to
create more than one file and it will
compile them all down to one css file
now that you have that we come back here
we can click the button that says watch
sas and this will start to compile
our sas so i've created that now you can
see it went to the output window here
and it will start to look for that now i
really don't need that right now and
matter of fact i can close it and it
will continue to watch see it says
watching
and what it did when i clicked that was
automatically created my dist folder
which stands for distribution
and inside that folder i have a css
folder
and inside the css folder the live sas
compiler created
a css style.min.css
it also created a map because that's the
default i haven't changed that we don't
really need the map but it doesn't hurt
anything
this minified css and that it will
actually be minified
code is what's created when live sas
compiler does that now there are some
settings that we could look at quickly
if we come to preferences in vs code
then go to
settings and then i type in live sas
we'll get to the live sas compiler
settings
and you can see it's got a few different
settings
auto prefix exclude list
formats and formats is what we'll look
at and notice it has a
settings.json it says edit in
settings.json so
i probably have settings that aren't the
default i don't really remember what the
default settings were
but i can show you what i've changed
mine to so the format that i have
in this settings json says compressed
and that means it's going to compress
the css down to a minified version
then there's an extension name and i end
my file with
dot min dot css which is the standard to
kind of tell you that file is compressed
and then it has the save path and i like
to save mine to a distribution folder
and in the future if you start using a
bundler like webpack
this will make more sense but i saved to
a distribution folder
and then the css folder and so those are
the settings that i have you may have
different default settings and that
would be okay too
i just wanted to show you how to get to
those settings if you want to change
them
and so now our live sas compiler is
watching anything we do
and it will compile that sas right away
and the live server is watching for
changes
and as there are changes it will
automatically update what is served from
our local server and we will see it over
here
in chrome so that is all ready to go now
our
style page is really just going to pull
in other files we create
and on the sas website it shows how to
do this
with the use or at use however live sas
compiler doesn't seem to be supporting
that at least the version that i have
you can look at the sas page and i'll
link to that
in the video description and of course
look at a tutorial for sas
and you can see if your version of live
sas compiler is supporting use but right
now i need to type
import is the way i can pull in a file
with the version i have
and i'm going to pull in a base file
and we may get an error first because it
doesn't exist but
i'll highlight this folder once again
and i'll create this base file
and you say base with an underscore
because this is a sas
partial and sas knows it's a partial
because it starts with the underscore so
our style
file will look for this base partial and
we'll start writing
what looks a lot like css in this base
file
the very first thing i like to do in my
base file is start to define
colors and i can do that because sas
supports
variables and so i define the first
color usually with a default
font color and the reason this is handy
is because then i know one place to go
in my sas files that has all of the
colors for the project and then i'll
just refer to these variables
in the project so i'm going to define a
few starting colors here
i've got a background color
and this color is a shade of blue that i
like
9 0 e2 and then we'll have a container
and i'll abbreviate background color
and here will be an off-white
and then a container border color
yeah it's just a one word it's fine just
so it makes sense to you
and anybody else that reads it if they
need to work on your code
and as long as you spell out what it is
a good description like that should work
for your variable name so there's
four color names to start with i'll save
that
and let's see what else we should put
well i'll use media queries later of
course to make this project responsive
and sas also supports something called
mixins
and we start out with just saying at
mixin
and now i'll put an mp here
and we'll put in the size variable and a
thank you to kevin powell who has a
great channel
on web design and he
is originally who i learned this from
instead of typing out all these media
queries
and it's a great way to do it so we
don't have to type all of this stuff
except one time
media only screen and then we'll put min
width and size
here that's where we pull in our size
parameter and now
we can just put at content
and that will be our mixin for future
use
when we need to use a media query now we
can start what looks more like just
regular css and i start with a reset
we've got the asterisk and that means
select all
this applies to all elements everything
on the page i've got a margin of zero
padding of zero and i like to put box
sizing
in my reset we'll set that at zero
and then i start with html and body
and i apply these to both elements
we put in some basics for the page or
the web app
and the first is font size 16 pixels i
never like to go below that
and we set that as our base for the
project
and then font family is another one and
we're going to pull
in a font from google fonts
so we'll take a moment to look at that
in just a second but i'll go ahead and
tell you what one i'm going to use
i like the font montserrat
and then we'll back that up just in case
it wouldn't load
with sans serif
okay color and this is the text color so
we go to our default font color that was
available
width we want 100 width on the html and
body elements
min height 100
and then we're going to include a media
query
so we'll include now we say mp
like we defined above and 768 which is
the ipad
size so once we've got to tablet size
from phone size
and we want to remember that we're
starting
with a mobile first design and you can
see we have
a mobile phone view over here actually
an iphone 8
layout in chrome in the dev tools
and this of course is the finished
product we want to start
small and build our way up
and if we need to change things as the
page gets bigger
or as the viewport gets bigger we can do
that
so the only thing i'm really sizing up
is the base size of the font
as the page gets bigger we're just
taking that font and going from a base
of 16 pixels
to 22 pixels now you can see in
everything else we're going to add to
the project
we're not going to refer to a font size
with a pixel anymore we will use rems
which will always come back and refer to
this
base size we've set in the html and body
okay let's save this and now let's add a
couple of things
to the body alone that we're not going
to add on to the html and one is
padding 20 pixels
all around and then the background color
and we'll use the background color we
defined
from there we can go to the section and
remember we've got two sections
here you can see we've got the
background color we just set on the body
is that blue color and now we've got our
two sections we're working with
so you can tell they will not be as wide
as the viewport they will have a
different background color
so let's set that background color
and it will be the container background
color that we defined kind of that
off-white
and then we'll set the width
to 90 percent now it doesn't look like
this is really a 90 percent width but
remember we set
padding of 20 pixels as well
on the body so 20 pixels in from
all sides and then instead of using a
hundred percent of the available width
we're using 90
of the available width so we've already
subtracted
40 pixels from the possible width and
then we're only using 90
of what's left okay
max width 700 pixels so when we get to a
larger screen
we don't want this to continue growing
beyond 700 pixels
margin we'll set those to auto and you
can see that's why the sections are
centered we've got a margin left and
right that is set to auto
and now a border one pixel
solid and we'll come back to our
container dash
border color that we defined
and then we'll round the corners with a
border
radius of 10 pixels
now why don't we see this applying to
our html yet
well let's go ahead and take a look at
this html
and we'll hide the file a little the
file tree for a second so we can see
everything a little better
and we don't have it linked yet we
haven't linked
our sas or the finished product which is
the css
is what we really need to link we
haven't linked that
to our html yet so of course we're not
going to see that
let's link it right up here above the
title
i'll put link and then rel
attribute equals stylesheet
and then href and this will link to what
we have and you can see the dist folder
and then there's the css folder and then
there's style.min.css so
visual studio code was helping us out
with everything
and as we save that now you can see what
we get
doesn't look great yet let's go ahead
and get the google font montserrat that
we talked about as well and what you
want to do is go to
fonts.google.com
and there type in montserrat
if i'm pronouncing that correctly even
and then we click on the result and it
will give us a list of available styles
and if i remember right i chose medium
500 so if you click select this style
it actually gives us the link we can
copy
and then of course it says what to put
in our css rules which is what i did
earlier
we had the font family and it's
montserrat and back that up with sans
serif so we'll just copy this link and
we will put this link
in our html oh there's something i must
have forgot i put
a semicolon there instead of just
closing out the link tag there we go
now let's go ahead and put this above
the style sheet we're creating
so this style sheet can actually use the
montserrat
font family as well so we'll save that
and now we can get rid of that and we
have it doesn't look much better but we
are using the correct font that we want
to at this time
okay we're ready to add another partial
and that is for our shared classes
between the buttons
so let's show the file tree once again
and we want to
add a partial file named
underscore sharedclasses.scss
now i want to define a few more colors
before we get started on the buttons
so we'll start with text box
dash border color because that is going
to be right up there where we're
working with the text box and the first
button
and then we'll have button
text color and that will be
white and then we'll have
button hover color
and that's when the mouse hovers over
the button
set that to dark or black and then we
can have
an add button color
and that is where we're adding an item
so that's going to be a green
and that is 4 c a f 5 0
and then we'll have our clear button
color and that will be 9 9f6060
there we go so we've got all the colors
we need
let's come over to the shared classes
partial and we'll start adding some code
for these button
classes so the first class is just
button and that's what we added in the
html
we'll set the width to 15 well i need
the percent
now we'll set the min width to 48 pixels
and the min height to 48 pixels
and that is the minimum size you want a
button especially when it is mobile
friendly because that is where you have
your thumb or your fingerprint your
fingertip
and if i remember right i read this from
google dev advocates but you don't want
a button smaller than that
48 pixels by 48 pixels is pretty much
the minimum
mobile friendly size for a button for
your finger to fit on it properly
so 48 by 48 are the min width and height
settings there
and now for the color we'll go with
button dash text color
that we set earlier and now border
two pixels solid and we'll go with
the text box border color we set now we
didn't set it specifically for the
button
but it's right beside that text box so
i'm just going to use the same one
and border radius 10 pixels that'll give
it that
rounded uh feel instead of just being
squared off in sharp corners
and then i'm going to set the outline to
none and this is usually
not good and let me tell you why this is
not good it needs to be
visually you need to somehow see
i guess that the focus
is on the button so something visual
needs to happen
and usually that is an outline many
screen readers will outline
by default anyway but you don't want to
remove the outline if you don't have
another plan
for the hover and the focus but we do so
let's set those next we'll take that
button class
and we'll choose the hover
and the first thing we want to do is
just change the cursor
to a pointer and that's where the cursor
changes from the arrow to the little
hand with the finger pointing
and now the next thing we want is not
only button
hover i'll put a comma and then we
also want to choose button focus
and now here we're going to do a couple
of things one is set this
filter property and we'll change the
brightness
and you can see it accepts a parameter
and we'll set that to a hundred
and twenty percent that means it's going
to get brighter
when we mouse over or focus
on the button it will lighten up the
color so that should be a visible change
we're also going to set a box shadow
which is kind of an outline in itself
so we'll set that to 4 pixels 2 pixels 5
pixels
and black and like a shadow
now that we've added our button classes
let's go ahead
and import that partial
we'll save that and let's see what we've
got going
in the live version of our code that
we're creating
so far again this is the example version
that we'd already created to start out
the project
and here's what we've got and i need to
close devtools so you can actually see
some of that
hover or mouse over in action you can
see
it brightens up the button although we
haven't styled the button the way we
want to yet
and we also brighten up this button but
we haven't applied the specific colors
or anything like that to the buttons yet
but we will okay we'll come back into
devtools
there we go let's look at this example
again of course we want these colors on
the buttons
and there's some other things we're
going to add as well so
we've got the shared classes partial and
the base partial
now we want to go ahead and tackle each
section on its own
and the next section or partial we will
add we can go ahead and do that here
first
import and we will call this
new item entry
so we need to add a file a partial file
that has the same title
new item entry dot s-c-s-s
although note we don't have to put the
file extension here sas
knows to look for these types of files
so now in the new item entry scss
we'll start out with that class and that
is what we applied in our html as well
new item entry and now everything
inside this because sas supports
nested styles everything inside this
class
will only be well it will only target
what's inside this class so this
is a parent is a way to put that so if i
just say
input at this point it's only going to
look for an
input inside this class because it's
nested
i want to start out with the position
sticky though
and that is because if our list gets
long enough i don't want our add
item area to scroll off the screen
so we'll make it so when it gets to zero
it'll just stick
and stay at the top and the rest of the
list can scroll underneath
and we do that with position sticky and
top
zero just those two settings you'll only
see that if you get a really long list
and then scroll through the list and
it'll just stop right there which we can
try that out later
margin on the bottom of this
we'll set to 1 rem
and then padding will set to
0.75 rem
and those are our main styles just for
the container
the new item entry container now
once again inside the class we're going
to use
nested styles and the first thing we're
going to target is the form
because remember the rest of this is a
form and it has
the text input and the submit button
so this display is going to be
flex and we're going to justify the
content to
space between
and that will have these two items the
input and the button
going as far left and as far right as
they possibly can
so i'll go ahead and save that and let's
see what changes are being implemented
here
yeah it looks a little different than it
did before it's definitely not what we
want yet but we're working on it
now inside the form we have a label
but you don't see the label let's look
back at the main one
you don't see the label here you see the
placeholder text but the label is
nowhere to be seen
but we still have a label and that is
for accessibility
however i'm going to style the label way
off the screen
i'll put the position as
absolute and then
i'm going to send it left and i'll put
minus
ten thousand pixels
and that will take that label way off
the screen but a screen reader
will still read that label because it
relates to the input
and now we can target the input
and we probably could just say input but
since we have a button
which is a submit type and you could
have an input with a type submit and
then it would show up as a button
it gets confusing so i'm going to just
get a little bit more specific here i'll
say
input type equals
text and so that's a way you can see how
to make a more specific selector there
based on the input type and i'll set the
width
to 80 percent
font size is going to be a little bit
bigger than the standard so
1.25 rem and then
border 2 pixel
solid text box
border color and then border radius
10 pixels once again to round those
edges
padding 0.75
rem that will give a little bit of space
inside the text
and then once again i'll set this
outline
to none but then i have to make sure i'm
doing
something with that input when we get
there
so we will have a focus and hover
setting for this input let's look at the
changes now
that looks a little better we're getting
there
okay so what will we do for the input
and once again i need to specify type
equals
text
oh focus comma yeah and then
input again type
equals text and
hover now let's add a box shadow
to that input
and let's come back and look at that
again
we'll close the dev tools here and we've
got a box shadow
over the text when we hover or when it
has focus the box shadow stays so that
is what we wanted there
let's come back to dev tools
and we can add a few more things here so
we've got the input taken care of
and this is our specific button now even
though we have our button class
in our shared classes partial we have a
button specific to our item entry area
and so within that class we're going to
target this button
this button element put font size
it's 1.25 rem
background color
it's going to be our add button color
padding 0.75 rem
at include let's include
our media query
font size of 1.5 rem
when the page gets up to tablet size and
that's where we just
increased the font size a little bit to
scale up
with the size of the page and let's save
all of that
okay we have one more partial to add and
that is for
our list container styles and so we will
add the extra partial
to our sas folder and we're going to
call it underscore
list container.scss
and we'll need to remember to go to our
style
and include that with the import
statement
and we'll say underscore list container
just import that partial as well okay
in the list container itself the first
thing we want to do is name the class
the same class we used in our html and
once again everything will be
nested within this class we'll set just
a couple of properties
for the class itself
we'll put a minimum height of
60 viewport height that's what i call it
viewport height
units um it's kind of like 60
whatever the viewport height is the
minimum height of this
will be 60 percent of the viewport
height
and so that gives it some room if you
don't have much in your
list at that point it'll still expand at
least to that 60 percent
and i think it looks just a little bit
better okay padding
we'll go ahead and add 0.75
rems here as well and now let's get into
the list
title if you remember we had that list
title class
nested within and that has the to-do
list title
it has the clear button in this section
right here
we're going to display in a flex
flex display flex box is what we're
using
justify the content again we'll do the
space
between like we did at the top for
our form so that'll take things far left
and far right
and here we're going to align items
and we'll put flex end instead of at the
beginning
from there we'll look at the button
that is inside the title
say font size one rem
background color here we'll do the clear
button color we defined
now for padding i'm going to set
the top to zero
and then we'll set well the top and the
bottom to zero actually
and then we'll set the sides to just
just a little bit of padding one
or 0.1 rem just to give it just a hair
of padding
okay margin at the bottom
0.5 rem that's
just to give it a little bit of space
between
the horizontal rule we have at the very
bottom and the button
okay and let's add a media query with
include and remember we defined our mix
and media query and this is once again
when it reaches the size of an ipad
tablet i'm going to change that font
size
now let's not change the font size it
can just stay where it's at
let's add padding just a little more
padding
so the top still and the bottom still
has zero
but the sides will now have 0.5 instead
of 0.1
rem okay there's a little bit
now besides the button we also have
a horizontal rule that we can do
something with
and we'll just set that width to 100 so
it goes
all the way across except there's a
little bit of space here
where we have that padding that we
defined up here at the beginning of the
container so that padding
is in the container but it takes up a
hundred percent of the width
available to it okay so
we're in the list container and we
defined everything in the list
title area now our buttons look right of
course here our title looks correct also
and we do have the horizontal rule so
that's all good
so now we need to go to the item area
and if you remember in the html
the item area is where we start adding
those list items
here we have our list item and inside
that were the items
themselves and we're going to
dynamically create these items
in our app so we need to go ahead and
style those
let's get back to our list container
and we've got the list title class and
we're finished with that so now let's
just go to the item class
and we'll also set that display to flex
and we'll justify the content
and we'll set that content to flex start
so this starts at the very top and then
we'll also
align items here and we'll center those
items
and we'll set uh the padding
on the top to one rem
we need a little bit of space there okay
the inputs
the inputs if you remember are check
boxes so here we'll specify the type
equals check box
and we'll get a little
room for the definition we'll go text
align
center
and we'll have the width and that would
be 2.5
rem to get a little bit bigger check box
there
the minimum width
kind of look at this like a button
because once again
could be touching that so we want 48 for
min width
min height will also want 48 pixels
just like we treated the buttons and
then height
itself which maybe we should have put
here before the min
height height will set to 2.5
rem also underneath the min height we
can
switch the cursor to a pointer
just like we would for buttons and then
margin
on the right because we want to give
some space between the check box
and the label set to 1.5
rem now let's go ahead
and add something for the focus that
will help our accessibility
once again identify the check box input
and we'll say focus but now there's one
more
thing to add here plus label
because this is the label out to the
side where you see eaton sleep or in the
finished version you see eat sleep code
this is because when we tab through
say using a keyboard or when we select
the item but when we tab
through and this item has focus we want
to underline those to-do items
we need to give it that extra visual for
the each item
like the the word eat or sleep needs to
be underlined and here we can do that
with a text
decoration and underline
that to do item and then for label
itself
and this is the label which is also the
to do item here
font size will set to 1.1 rem just a
little bit bigger than normal
and let's go ahead and save that
oh this looks much more like it okay a
quick correction
i was trying to figure out why i was
scrolling left and right
and yet the original that i had designed
was not of course
and it shouldn't be i went back and i
was in a hurry
and on box sizing after setting margin
and padding to zero
i made the mistake of putting a zero for
box size and we don't want that we want
border box is the value that we need
and now you will see
well it's still moving just a little bit
here but i think if we close
dev tools as this sometimes happens and
then if i put it back
into there we go put it back
in now it's not scrolling left and right
at all sometimes you have to open and
close dev tools
to get your mobile simulator to
adapt just right so now it won't scroll
left and right at all and that's exactly
what we want so everything is as it
should be
with the border box setting i had
mistakenly set that to xero before
with that our sas is completed our app
is styled and we are ready to move on to
the javascript
we're now ready to move on to the
javascript of our project
and so we want to create a javascript
folder
let's go ahead and just name that js
and inside the javascript folder we're
going to have more than one file
let's start out with a to-do list.js
file and i want to create a class for
our to-do list this isn't going to be an
app where we can have
multiple to-do lists we're just going to
have one major to-do list
and so it's not too complicated we'll
start with an export
and this will be the default export as a
matter of fact the only class in this
file
and it will be a to-do list
so we have to have a constructor
in this constructor we'll have this dot
underscore list
and it will equal an empty array to
start out with
and now we'll have a few methods
or kind of a getter and setter if you
will will definitely have
a get list
and with that we will return this dot
underscore list
we'll also have a clear list
so we can empty out the contents of the
list
and for that we'll just set it equal to
an empty array once again
and what else can we add add
item to list
now here we'll need an item object
because each to do is going to be its
own
object and with this one we'll have this
dot underscore list dot push
item object and we'll push the item into
the array
and then of course we need to be able to
remove one
item from the list so we'll have remove
item from list
and we'll supply the id of the to do
item
when we remove it this will be just a
little bit longer
than the other methods we've added here
so we'll define a list
and it will be equal to the list
and then we'll say 4 let i
equal 0 and while i
is less than the list length
we will loop through
and now we'll say if
the list item which would be represented
by the list with the iterator in bracket
notation
and then dot underscore id so this is
specifically the id number if it equals
id and we're not using a strict equals
here
that's because we're going to grab the
id
from the dom and we'll just grab it
right out of the attribute so it won't
necessarily be a number it will probably
be a string value at that point
and so we'll just use the two equal
signs instead of the three for strict
equals and at this point we can splice
to remove the item
and we'll start with the iterator and
then we'll use the number one
because we're only removing that one
element from the array and then
we're finished with the loop so we can
break at that point
we'll save that and there is our to-do
list class
now we need to create a to-do item class
which will also be fairly simple
so let's go ahead and add another file
and call this to do item js
and then to do item js it'll start out
much the same way
export default
class to do item
now unlike the list we're going to
create mini to do items
we'll start with a constructor it'll be
this dot underscore id
equals null to start out with this
dot underscore item
will equal null also
no predetermined values there so then
we'll have a getter
a get id it's going to return
[Music]
this dot underscore id
then we'll have a setter with a set id
and i prefer to use methods named like
this rather than the get
and set keywords it just reads
better to me throughout the code it's
easy to see what's going on
oh and with the setter we we need to
pass in the id
as a parameter we'll have this dot
underscore id
equals id now we'll also get the
item
and we'll return this dot
underscore item and then
we'll have a set item and here we need
to pass in the item
along with this dot underscore item
equals item and that is
our to do item class so you can see we
just
really have the two properties in the
constructor and we have getters
and setters for each of those properties
okay we'll put the rest of the
javascript for this project
in a file that i typically name main js
main.js and in this main.js file the
first thing we want to do
is import our to-do list
from the to-do list
dot whoops dot js
and then we'll import to do
item from
to do item there we go
dot js
and then we'll create a to-do list
object from the to-do list class
so it's a new to-do list
and now at this point we haven't added
the script tag to our html yet so we'll
need to go back and do
that
and we'll come up to the top i'm going
to go ahead and hide the file tree again
just so we can see a little better and
we need to add that script tag
when we add the script tag and i'll do
that below
the css link
we identify the source
starts in our js folder and
then it will be our main js
but we also need to add type
equals module because we're using
imports
and it has a closing script and that
should be good
i'll show the file tree once again and
we'll go back to the main js file
now i can probably hide that and give us
a little more room
and we'll go ahead and get started by
adding the very first
function and that function should be
what
listens for the load event that we're
listening for
but it's not specifically the load event
but we're going to add a document
and then add event listener directly to
the document and we're listening for the
ready state
change and with that event
we will fire uh well we'll listen here
if event dot target
dot ready state we'll listen for that
and now a strict equals
equals complete and that means the dom
is fully loaded
and ready to interact with if we get to
this point we're ready to
launch our init app function
and so now we're ready to get started
and what would go in our init
app well we won't add everything right
away
but our init app and i'll make an arrow
function here for it
we'll have our event listeners so we're
going to add
listeners here and then it's also
going to have a couple of procedural
items that we're going to call other
functions we're going to make
and so i'll put here procedural things
that we want to do
right when the app loads one is going to
be to
load our list
or our list object and especially if we
store that in
any persistent data if we use our web
storage api
to do that we're going to want to load
those list items out of there when we
come back to visit so they're still
there
the other thing we want to do is refresh
the page
and that can have a few items within it
so
let's go ahead and create that function
right now so our refresh
the page function is what would be
called into action
so we need to create that function below
it
and it is going to contain a few helper
functions
kind of a procedural function of its own
so we'll define refresh
the page
doesn't need any parameters and one
thing we're going to do
is clear the list
display so that's a function on its own
another thing we're going to do is
render the list
a third thing we will do is clear
the item entry field that would be that
text input where we're entering things
we don't want
leftovers hanging out there and the
final thing we want to do is set the
focus
on the item entry field
we don't want to be somewhere else and
always have to click in the box or tab
back to it we always want the focus
set back to that item entry and ready to
go right when the page loads or whenever
we decide to refresh the page
so there we essentially have a
procedural function here that's calling
for helper functions and we'll start
with the clear the list display
so how will we do that we'll define our
clear
list display function which will also be
an arrow function
and from there we need to define a
parent element
so that's exactly what i'm going to call
that variable
and we'll select the parent element from
the document with the document get
element by id and we're going to look
for the list
items container that will be the parent
element for all of the list items
and now we're going to create another
helper function that deletes
the contents of whatever
element we feed this function so we need
to feed it a parent element
and that's what we defined so one more
helper function here
and we're breaking these into smaller
functions because they're easier to
manage
and you really only want your functions
to do one thing
if they're not procedural functions and
a
procedural function like refresh the
page should be calling these other
functions
that are only doing one thing each and
sometimes
when we get something like clear the
list display if we determine that it
needs
its own helper function we can break
that out as well
so now let's define this delete contents
this delete contents function isn't
necessarily just
for this web app this could be used in a
variety of web apps
and honestly it's a function that i use
in almost
every web app that i create with vanilla
javascript because it's just a function
that will delete all of the child
elements of a parent element so let's go
ahead and define that
let's say let child and we'll set it
equal to
oh we need to pass in the parent element
we're calling that before so
i'll just call it the same thing here
parent element
let child equal parent element
and then last element
child and then we'll say
while child
so while there is a child element we'll
say parent
element dot remove child
that's a method will pass in the child
so it removes the child
while there is a child and then the
child
is going to equal the parent
element dot last element child
once again and that is if there is
another one
then you reset it to that last element
child
and you continue that process until
they're all gone
so we can save that and now our clear
list display function is complete
so we call that and it selects the
parent
and then we pass the parent in to delete
contents and those contents are deleted
okay now let's look at the render list
function
that's the next one called in line so
we'll say const
render list
and this would set into action the
processes that
render our to-do list so we'll define a
list inside of here
and we'll say to-do list remember this
is the new
to-do list object we created at the
beginning
and now we want to call in that method
get
list right now of course it would be an
empty list
but we're still getting the list and
then we'll say
list and it's an array so we can use
four each
and this is for each item on the list
we will call a helper function which is
build
list item and we'll pass in the item
from the array that single item
we'll save that so now we know we need a
build
list item function to help out our
render list
so let's define that build list
item and it's going to accept item as a
parameter
and now this function gets just a little
longer because we're creating
dom elements like divs and we're setting
attributes so
we'll start out with a div and really we
could go back
to our html and just take a quick peek
because what we're creating
is what i commented out here that i
could bring back in
and now i'll hide the file tree and give
us a little more room
right here this is what we're creating
now why don't they show up huh well
it could be that our clear
list function is working
if we come back into our main js file
and come to the top and we comment out
our clear list display
function now they load in
just like they were so we know our clear
list display function
is working so that's great and this is
how they should look
and it's what we're going to be creating
with this build
list item so once again quick look at
the html
and we're going to be creating a div
with the class of item
and inside that div we're going to have
a checkbox
input and a label and there's several
attributes that they'll have as well
so now back at whoa
back at the js in our main js file
let's do this build list item function
so we start with the div
it's document dot create
element and we pass in a div
so we know that's the type of element
we're creating we've set it equal to the
variable div so then we can just say div
dot class name
to set the class equals item
now let's build our check box so once
again document.create
element we have an input element that is
a check box
and we'll say check dot type
equals check box that's the attribute
there
and then check dot id
equals the item we've passed in
which is a to do item so it has the
method get id
that was our getter for the id attribute
and then check dot tab index
because it needs to have that tab index
attribute so it's part of the tab order
so we can tab between the items
so we'll set that tab index to zero
that is good so far and you can see how
we're creating those elements and there
could be some of you that would say
hey you should have a separate function
for each one of these elements you're
creating and that is a possibility
because that would really
break it down to doing one thing each
and i just haven't broken it out that
far we're going to end up with a
function that has about 15
lines here right here i'm going to add a
comment
but we want to add a click
listener to check box
and we pass in check which would be
the check variable so this is going to
be a helper function we will come back
to that
now we'll define a label variable we'll
say
document dot create
element pass in label
now our label is going to have a four
attribute
but in javascript that is html4
looks just a little different that is
item.getid because you want the four
attribute of the label to be
identical to the id of
the check box okay
label dot text content now we're setting
the
actual text of the label it will be item
dot
get item
and now we want to append what we've
created
so div dot
append child so we have our div and
we're going to append
the check box and then right after that
we'll have div
dot append child and we're going to
append the label
and now we need to go ahead and create
the container
or at least select the container we're
not going to create the container
what am i thinking so this is document
dot
get element by id
and it's our list items container
and from there we can just say container
dot
append child and pass in the div
well that's all right so all we haven't
done is create that helper that adds the
listener to the check
box but everything else looks good so
let's come back up because this was the
helper to the render list
and here's the render list function well
the list is empty so it doesn't have
anything to render at this point we're
going to have to
go back and tell it how to create
an item very soon so we can start doing
that but right now
we can render the list which calls the
build list item
function and from there we need to go
ahead and create
a helper function that is called add
click listener to check box so that way
when the user clicks on that check box
something happens now check boxes do
have their
natural behavior of adding a check to
the box
we don't really have to do anything to
make that happen
but let's create this helper function
here that says
add click listener to check box
and we're going to pass in the check box
that we're adding the listener to
and now inside this function we can say
check box dot add event listener
listing for the click event
and we could pass in the event here
although we're not really doing anything
with it
we've just listened for it and now when
it's clicked
we can call the to-do list
remember that's our object that we
defined up in the global space above
that is our overall to-do list
and we can call remove item from list
because that's when we're checking it
off we want to remove an item
we can pass in the check box
id and the check box id
that we had grabbed or it has that
attribute that was
set and we're grabbing that from
the element itself so there's the check
box id we're passing in
and now at this point besides removing
the item from the list there
we and that is removing it from the
object we're removing the to do item
we would also want to remove it
from uh the persistent data so i'm just
putting a to do reminder here
remove from persistent
data and we'll come back to that as well
and notice i also have a little
extension i'm using for to-do's
that does this and we could look that up
but pretty much go to your extensions
and search for to do and you'll find an
extension that highlights to do's for
you
the one extra thing i want to add is
this will happen
so fast when we would check a box to
remove it
that i would prefer to slow that down or
at least
not refresh the page so quickly that
it's just a blur
because you get a little bit of
satisfaction out of seeing the check
mark
in the box yes i've checked this item
off so i want to use
the set timeout
that is built into the window object
this is one of those things that you
could say window.settimeout but you
don't have to
use the word window and so i'm using the
set timeout and inside this set
timeout i'm going to call
the refresh the page function
and that will refresh the page delete
the previous items
load the new list because we have added
an item to the list
it doesn't just automatically add to the
dom we have to
once again pull that data from the dom
and i'm going to set the timeout to one
second
this is a thousand milliseconds which is
one second so we get the satisfaction
of seeing that check box or our item
that we have worked hard on and checked
off
our to-do list for at least one second
before it disappears
so we'll save that and other than having
it to do for the persistent data
we have finished that so now when we
build a list item
it's going to add a click
and apparently i'd mistyped listener
it's going to add a click
listener if we spell that right
to every item when we build it and we
build these items in a loop so for each
item in the list we build the item
so every item also gets a click listener
attached to it
now that we've completed the add click
listener to check box function
except for the to do that we have
remaining and
the build list item that all comes back
to our render list we called
we just have a couple of small items
left in our refresh the page function
one is clear the item entry field which
is
our text entry and the other is
set focus on item entry which would just
set the focus
back here so we could start typing right
away without having to click in the box
or click a button or tab through so
let's go ahead and create those
functions
and those are quick and easy as far as
that goes so
we'll come down here under our add click
listener to check box function
and we'll start with the clear item
entry field function
does not need a parameter
so all we need to do is select the item
entry field
get element by id and that is
new item
and then we'll at that value
equal to a blank value
we'll save that and that is that
function that just clears out
the text input box and the other
function we needed
was set focus
on item entry
once again no parameters needed
we'll set the focus element by id
and we'll get that new item input again
and here we'll just say focus
and that will set the focus back to that
input and i've noticed we're still using
the iphone
5 the smallest view which is what i like
to do because it's
always easier to expand and make it
bigger but we can go ahead
and possibly expand our phone just a
little let's get a different phone
choice
maybe an iphone 8
and we can see fit to window it'll let
us go a little bigger there with a 91
that's great
that gives us a nice clear view it adds
just a little space i felt like the
iphone 5 look was a little cramped
so there we have everything needed in
our refresh
the page function
and it is a procedural function that
calls these other four functions
and these functions at least the first
two also had some helpers
so we've completed all of that now we're
probably anxious to start
adding uh items to our list and to see
some of this in action for sure so let's
get started with that
what we need to do or is add event
listeners
then in our initial initialize app or
init
app function so we'll come back up to
the top where we add the listeners
and let's go ahead and start with some
of that the first thing we want to do
is select the entry form
and there we go document dot get
element by id once again and it is the
item
entry form so we've selected that entry
form
and now we can say item
entry form dot add event listener
and we're listening for the submit
because this is a form so when the form
is
submitted listen for that submission
event
or submit event and what we want to do
let me go ahead and save this real quick
and show you why we want to do this
right now forms have the default
behavior that
they submit via a get method even if you
don't define that in your html so
watch the elements over here to the
right when i
click the submit button everything
flashes
it actually reloads because it submits
the form
we don't want that to happen we want to
handle the
data ourselves we don't need to submit
that form so what we want is an event
as we specified in our parameter the
event
prevent default and that will prevent
that from happening so now when i click
the button watch over here
nothing flashes we can click submit as
much as we want to but we've prevented
the default behavior of the form
and it doesn't reload everything like
the dom
it happens so fast you don't really see
it here but you can see it here in the
code
so we've done that and now we need to
essentially
process the submission
and that's what i'm going to call this
function and that
is once again a procedural function a
little bit larger
that does a few things when we process
the submissions so we'll get started
with that
we need to scroll all the way down
underneath our set focus on item entry
function
and we'll start defining the process
submission function
no parameter necessary to start out with
the very first thing we need to do is
grab the text the item what has been
entered so we'll say const
new entry text and we'll set that to a
function named
get new entry
and as you might guess this function is
just going to do the one thing and
that's what we want functions to do
if at all possible get new entry
and we're going to return
the document.getelementbyid
new item once again value
but also trim that value we don't want
the white spaces to the left or the
right that might exist
so we've got the new entry item now by
calling that simple function
and now we'll say if
the new entry text
dot length is false which would be zero
so that's how we could say if it is
equal to zero
uh return just exit the function
and we're done nothing else needs to
happen there
but if there is some length to the text
there's at least
at least one character there something
that we want to put on our to-do list we
need to go ahead and process this
submission
so first thing we need to do is get the
next
item id because we might already have
items on our list and if we don't
it's clearly going to be the first item
but we need to have a function to do
that so we're going to say calc
next item id
and now we need to create a helper
function called that
so we'll start here and we'll say
calc next item id
start the arrow function and we'll add
let next item id
equal one because that's what it will be
if no items exist so we might as well
start out with that
value and then we'll grab the list
from our to-do list object by calling
the get list method
just set that equal to list and now i'll
say if
list.length greater than zero
the next item id is going to equal
now we're going to refer to the last
item on the list and we do that by
saying
list dot length
minus one and that refer using bracket
notation there with our
list array that would be the last item
on the list
and now we could say get id
we'll call the id for that last item
then we need to add one to it and that
would be the next item
and of course if it was not greater than
zero
then we just return the next item id
which would be one and there is our calc
next
item function okay so after we calc the
next item
id we need to go ahead and create
an item so now we say const
to do item equals
create new item now we've got a couple
of pieces of data already
and since they exist we need to go ahead
and create this item we say
next item id is passed in as a parameter
and also the new entry text
is a parameter for creating that
new item okay creating the new item we
just scroll down below
and create that function and we'll say
create
new item and we're going to set this
equal to an arrow function actually also
so we'll say
item id because we're passing in the
next item
id and then we'll say item text
because we've passed in the text as well
oh yeah arrow function
almost forgot again and now we need to
create a new to-do item so we'll say to
do
equals new to do
item this is a new object created from
our to do item class
and we'll start using those methods so
we'll set the id
equal to item id and i'll say to do
set item equal to
item text and then we'll just return
the to do
that was easy enough so if we come back
now our to-do
is held in this to-do item variable
now that we have our to-do item we can
just call our to-do list
into action this is our to-do list
object that we've created and it has the
add
item to list method so we just call that
method
and pass in the to-do item
now a note here again another
reference to it to do this is to do in
our code
this is where we would want to update
our persistent
data once again because we've added a
new item so that would need to go into
that storage as well
so what we're seeing is anytime we
update our to-do list
whether it's adding an item or removing
an item we also need to update our
persistent data
and then when this is all completed we
need to
refresh the page again and that is
because we have added a new item
and so that page needs refreshed and it
will now show the new item as well
and it's not like refreshing a web page
in
completely this will happen so fast that
you won't even
realize that all the items have been
deleted and shown again it will look
like just one new item appears
if you can believe it we are almost
finished with the app we still need to
add something for our clear
button and we need to handle our
persistent data one quick correction
this new to do item needs to start
with a capital t as when we import these
classes you can see the lowercase
t on my to-do here but when we scroll to
the top
we can see we're importing these with
capital ts capital letters because
they're classes that we have imported so
that needs to be a to-do item
with a capital t now that said let's go
ahead and check out
our process submission function where we
could say eat
and we could say sleep you notice the
focus goes right back to the input and
we can say code and that all works like
we want but we could also say sleep
more and tab over to the
submit button and hit enter there and
when we hit enter it goes back and sets
the focus
back into the text input like we need so
that's also very convenient
and that submit function
is doing all of that is not submit the
submit
event is what is happening there
and that is triggering the rest of that
we didn't need to
have any other click event listener or
anything else it's just the forms
submit event that is making that happen
when that fires
whether it's from the submit button or
from us hitting enter because this is a
one input form so we can just press the
enter key
and it works just as well of course we
can tab through all of these and you see
the
items get underlined
and the hover
and focus were focused on the clear
button they were focused on the submit
button
or focused back on the text input all
work like they should so let's go ahead
and finish up this app
by adding a listener for the clear event
button
or the clear button and listen for its
click event
and then we could also finish up by
adding the persistent data
so let's scroll to the top and add the
other listener that is missing
for that clear event or the the click
event
on the clear button
starting out we'll define our clear
items
variable and we'll grab
the element we need which is the button
document
get element by id once again
and we'll grab the clear items id which
is the button
and now we'll say clear
items dot add event listener
listen for the click on that button
and pass in the event even though we
won't really need the event
in there and we want to say
get the list which is the to-do list
object we've created and we'll say get
list again
once we have that we'll say if list dot
length that means if it has a length
that is not zero if there's length to
the list we want to
use a confirm a little confirm window
so we'll say confirm and the message is
are you sure you want to clear
the entire list question mark
and of course we need a semicolon there
i want to go ahead and wrap this so it's
not
scrolling off the screen there we go are
you sure you want to clear the entire
list and after we ask that
if confirmed because confirmed will
the confirm window will return or the
confirm pop-up will return a boolean so
it's either true or false whether
they click ok or cancel
and so if confirmed if we click ok and
it comes back true
we'll say to-do list which is our object
called the clearlist method that we've
already defined
to do here update
persistent data once again
because we've cleared out the full list
so at that point
the persistent data should also get
emptied out and then we'll say
refresh the page
because anything that was displayed
should be deleted from the list
and so that is the event listener for
the clear button
so let's add a few things let's say eat
sleep code and now let's click the clear
button
and we get our confirm we'll say okay
and it cleared the full list likewise if
we said
eat sleep code we had two different ones
it doesn't really matter
and we clicked and then we got the
confirm and we click cancel
then it doesn't and that's the behavior
we wanted so that is great
and that finishes the clear button
action
so now we need to handle this persistent
data
and that is in several places in our
codes here so let's look from the top
let's look for all the to-do lists we
might see and the very first thing we
see
is update persistent data and i think
we're going to see that several times
throughout there
see we're on line 30 we have an update
persistent data
whereas our next to do on line
88 remove from persistent data
and that could just be update the
persistent data again because we could
just grab the list after it's been
removed from the list
and then online 109 we have an update
persistent data so we need to do that in
several places
let's just add our update persistent
data
right under our add click listener to
check box function
and it's not a big function at all
update persistent data we're going to
pass
in the list array
and there we'll use the local storage
and we'll set the item and now we need
to name what we
we're going to call our storage i'm
going to call it my to-do list
now we need to use json stringify
local storage works great with json
so we're going to stringify our list
array because
local storage only stores strings
anyway it will convert it even if we
don't use
the json so we might as well use json
and take advantage of that
and that is the full function that we
need to update
the persistent data so now let's just
look for the places
that call for that persistent data to be
updated
and call this function update persistent
data
and inside we'll always pass the to-do
list
get list so as long as the list has been
updated whether it's had something
removed or something added
this will update the persistent data so
i'll copy that and we'll just look for
these other places in our code that
needed it
any other to do is highlighted i think
there might be one at the top
yes there is
now we have updated our persistent data
in all of the places we need it so when
we come back
if we leave the site and come back maybe
even a week later
our to-do list will still remain and the
only thing we haven't done now
is one of the things we talked about at
the very beginning
and that is to load the list object
we need to load it out of our web
storage
and read that into our app right when
the app starts up
so let's call that a function
and we'll just call it load
list object and then we get to define
that function
so we'll put it let's say let's put it
right above the refresh
the page function because that's where
it's called in our code as well so
load list object make it an arrow
function
and besides the event listeners and of
course the init app that it's
within is the very first function that
actually
does something other than listening for
the app to start so
what we'll start out with is defining
our stored list
we'll say local storage dot get
item and we're getting my to-do list
out of local storage
so now that we've grabbed the list if it
exists we need to see if it exists and
i'm
going to say if the type of
so i'm checking the type of data that's
coming out here the type of the stored
list
if it's not equal to string then it's
really not what we're expecting so
just abort mission at that point so if
the stored list
is not equal to a string and it should
be string data that's definitely what
we're storing we're stringifying json
and putting it in there
but if it's not get out of there
so if the list exists and it's what we
expect
it will be stringified json data so now
we can say
const parse list
and call jsonparse and put the stored
list in here
and parse that out and now we should
have our parsed list
that would be the object we brought back
in so
now we can say parsed list
for each because this json is going to
have our item objects
in it so we have item objects so we'll
say for each item object
create a new to do item
and this is because our to-do items have
methods so we're not just pulling the
data out we want those methods
but when we stringify or even if we
didn't stringify if we just stuck them
into
the local storage or with the web
storage
they lose those methods those methods
don't stick with them when we pull them
back out so we want to just
create new items again remember this is
when the app loads
so we know we have a list of items now
we're actually making each item
a to-do object again and storing it in
the list
so this is why we take this approach so
we create a new item
new to do item and we have to call our
create new item
function that we previously defined and
we can pass in the item
object now here we don't get to use the
getter or the setter because they don't
exist
so we have to refer to those properties
and we refer to the item object
underscore id and item object
dot underscore item
and then we call that to-do list object
that we created
at the top so it already exists and then
we call the method from it
add item to list and we add the new to
do
item we just created of course we do
this
for each item on the list
okay let's clear out our list
let's add some more items let's say we
need to get
eggs milk bread
and chips can't live without chips maybe
tacos too
okay we've got eggs milk bread chips and
tacos
let's check our storage we go to the
application tab
and now we might have to pull this over
a little further
but we do have some local storage here
on my to-do list
and down here we can see each item
actually
and here is the id one two three four
five
and we've got eggs milk bread chips
and tacos let's check some more of our
app let's delete
bread there's the nice check box for one
second before it's gone
and now you can see we've got items one
two four and five so our persistent data
updated right away
and that's exactly what we wanted and
maybe i'll go ahead and delete one more
let's get rid of the chips
okay great now let's add something here
let's say
we want to add noodles
you can see we created the next item id
based on the last one
even though three and four were missing
we didn't create an item with an id of
three we grabbed the last item
and added one and it creates the next
item id
as it should i believe we are finished
creating our app
so let's review everything i'll scroll
this back over give us a little more
room
and let's even close this out and see
how it looks on a bigger screen so we
could really
add a longer item go to the store
and buy milk uh if i could smell milk
eggs and cheese and it's there
but we can add more and more
and more and more
and more and even one more
and now let's scroll and our sticky
item entry works also it stops at the
top
that's great so now we can click click
click can we click to it once
yes just have to be quick or it
disappears and comes back so if we went
click
and then hesitated it would maybe not
work as well
but we can try to debug it and even
refine this there's a lot of room for
improvement in this app this is a very
basic
to-do list application and i'm sure you
can add
more features that would even make it
better and of course in the long run you
might want to create an app that will
handle more than one list and you could
select which list you're working with
all right let's test out our to do web
app
and the first thing we want to do is uh
activate the chromevox
screen reader and see how it responds
we've already used the functionality we
know we can add items and remove items
with a mouse so we're really going to
test out the accessibility
features so go to the three dots in
chrome
and then choose more tools and choose
extensions
from extensions you'll want to activate
the chromevox classic edition
if you don't have that extension go to
chrome.google.com
and let's see what the rest of that
address is
it looks like i think you could just
search for the chrome
web store but it's chrome.google.com
webstore slash
category extensions and that would
probably get you there but go there
and search for chrome vox vox
and i can expand the browser a little i
believe so we can see that
and choose the chromevox classic
extension
that's what you want see if i can bring
this back
where we had it there we go right about
there
so we'll choose this and it's going to
start talking to us
i'll choose the to-do list to-do list
tab and it's ready to go
edit text so that's our text box
we can tab through add new item to list
enter a new to do item with hint add
item
edit text add new item to list
section remove all items from the list
i don't think i like that so well i
think we need to
change our section and maybe add a tab
indexed to our h1 so to do list remove
all items from the list
section there we go every time i click
it's reading something off
let's go ahead and try adding a text
so i'll say eat tea and i'm typing a
little fast if i type slower
e a t i'll
press enter eat deleted
oh i don't like that either i don't like
how it says eat deleted we want it to
say eat
and then added or item added something
like that
let's try another one sleep
and address and search bar
okay we tabbed 127.0.0.1 colon 55
edit text add new item to
list enter a new to do item with hint
add item
text that's interesting after i pressed
the enter
button or pressed enter when i had the
focus on the button
it just went back and read the uh
item entry field again because uh we
switched the focus back to that so i'll
go ahead and enter code
c code
deleted definitely don't like that let's
tab down and see what happens when we
remove something
add new item to list section
remove check box not checked
sleep check box not checked
checked enter a new to do item with hint
add item
edit text section so it really didn't
say it removed the item
and i pressed the space bar not enter to
actually check the check box
which is the actual behavior that i was
expecting
so there's a couple of things here we
want to change let's get to work on just
a few things we can fix
in this web app okay i want to start
with just a little bit of code
clean up and that's always good to do as
you're wrapping up a project
the very first thing is we get to the
colors and i'm remembering that i
really didn't use the button dash
hover color and we can verify that
by selecting the sas folder
and then right clicking and choosing
let's see
find in folder and i'm just going to
paste the name in there so this will
search all of the files
inside the sas folder and yes we've only
got this one occurrence which is right
here so we can just
get rid of this definition
it's part of our cleanup
save that file and
what else are we looking for oh yeah i
used mp
really wasn't thinking about it and i
meant to use
mq and i used it throughout so
we can also search for this within
the sas folder and see how many
occurrences of
mp or actually mp and the
beginning parenthesis might be a little
easier to find exactly what we're
looking for
so if we do that and choose find in
folder
we have four results in three files and
we can go to each one of those results
so here's the very first one and what i
want to do is change that to
a queue for media query if i had even
been thinking about it that only makes
sense
okay now we have three results and three
files because it automatically updates
so now i'll go here and we need to
change the rest of these to match our
definition
and that's the two results inside of
the base now we've got one in the list
container
and we've got one in the new item entry
with that fix in place i want to go back
to the html
and add that tab index to the header
and that way when we tab using the
screen reader
into this section it's going to read the
to-do list and not
the remove all items because that's not
what this section
is about it's really about the to-do
list
okay the last thing we need to do is
going to take just a little bit more
work in our javascript
and we'll go ahead and get rid of the
file tree so we have some more room
and this was when we added the item
the screen reader was saying deleted
because
immediately following pressing enter and
the item being added to our list
we were clearing out this text field and
so it said deleted
likewise when we checked a box instead
of
saying removed and say code removed or
eat removed
it simply said check box checked and
then went back here
and we could make this much more
informational
so we're mostly going to do this in
javascript
there is one thing we want to change
actually in
the html so i will go to the html first
hide that file tree so we're in our list
container section
and then we're in the list items section
right underneath the list items section
but still inside the list container
section
i'm going to just put a paragraph
element and i'm going to give this an id
of confirmation because we just want an
audible confirmation
i need to put a little more than that
i'm also going to put a class equal to
confirmation and
i'm going to set an aria dash live
attribute and this will be set to
assertive because
that means it's going to read
whatever happens in this element
immediately even if it interrupts what
it's saying
it's going to be assertive about it you
can also set this to polite and it will
wait but we want it to say right away
what it is doing and this will be
say eggs added or added to the list
or we could say eggs removed or eggs
removed from the list something like
that so whatever content we put in here
and that's all we need to do in the html
is add this
paragraph block element
and put the id class
and the aria live attribute and set it
to assertive
we'll save that and let's make sure
i need to drag this over just a little
bit more
we're not watching the sas let's go
ahead and do that so it updates the css
and compiles it as we go
continue watching even though i closed
that window
and now inside the
not the new item entry inside the list
container
is where we have added this and
inside that list container we're going
to go to the very bottom underneath
the label and
underneath the item area here
there we are you can see that
because this is not an item it's
actually in the list container section
which we're still within
and we can just say dot confirmation
which is the class we applied
to our paragraph element and i'm going
to do the same thing you saw me do
with the label for our
text entry we're going to have an
absolute position
and then we're going to set it minus 10
000
pixels to the left so this is going to
be off screen
it's nothing we need to see on screen we
can use the app
as intended already that way when we
look at it
but if someone needs a screen reader
they need this audible update so we're
going to actually put the update
information
in this paragraph in the confirmation
and since it has that aria live
attribute it will read that confirmation
with the screen reader
so now all we need to do is get to the
javascript
and go ahead and create the functions
that will enable this to happen
okay i'm going to scroll down in the
javascript
we're going to scroll way down here
towards the end
and we've got our process submission and
then we add the item
to the list and we update the persistent
data
this would be a good time to give
that screen reader confirmation that we
want to do so let's create a function
called
update
screen reader confirmation
and let's give this function two
parameters one we want to put the new
entry text in because
that is the item that we're adding to
the list so that's the new
entry text as a parameter the other one
let's call it
action verb and this is whatever
we want to kind of say after we add it
so we could just say added
or added to list something like that
i'll just call it action verb as a
parameter
so let's take this function name
and go to the bottom of the file here
underneath the create new item
and we'll create a function called
update screen reader confirmation
and it's going to accept the new
entry text and it's going to accept an
action verb
and since we're calling that up here now
we've talked about that
really we don't want to say action verb
here we want to say what we're doing so
let's say
added that is our action verb for now
now in the function we're going to get
that
element document get element by id
and we gave it an id of confirmation
and from there we can access the text
content
and we can set that text content equal
to a template literal
so we can put these parameters right
inside and we can say
new entry text imagine we added tacos to
our list so we'll say new entry text
and then space and action verb which is
added so we could say tacos added when
we're finished i'll go ahead and put a
period there
just to make it a sentence even if it's
a brief one
and we'll save that let me go ahead and
wrap that code so we can see it all at
once
something the reason this is white i am
not sure why this is white right now
something seems off i know what it is
been staring at code for too long i
forgot to make it an arrow function
there we go so there's our full function
update screen reader
confirmation and this will accept
say tacos and added and then it will
set that text content to that
confirmation paragraph that we have for
the screen reader and since it has the
aria
live attribute the screen reader will
read it
immediately as it's updated and so that
is why we have it
in our process submission we update the
persistent data
the very first thing we do is add the
new to do item to the list then we
update the persistent data and then we
give that confirmation
and it will read it right as it
refreshes the page and shows the new
item
so that is what we need there now
there's one other area
and that is when we remove an item and
that is just a little more complex
so let's scroll up to that click
listener we have for the check boxes
where we actually remove the item
and you can see we access the to-do list
and we remove an item from the list
and once again we update the persistent
data
and right after that or even before the
persistent data either way
it would be a great place to put that
update screen reader confirmation
so i'll just put it after because that's
what we did before
we can say update screen reader
confirmation
and this is going to accept some remove
text and we haven't defined that yet
and then we'll say
deleted or we could say
removed from list let's do that
i don't think we need the period there
though
because we already put that in our
template literal
okay so we need to define this remove
text now
what could we do to do that we have to
think about this where is the text it's
not in the check
box it's in the label so we need to
write a function
a helper function that is going to grab
that label text
based on the check box id so
let's do it right after our removed item
from list where we worked with the check
box id
and we could say const
remove text because that's what we're
passing in is the remove text
let's call this function git label text
and we're going to pass in the check box
dot id
so we'll pass in the id of the check box
now let's define that function just
right underneath
it's called get label text it's going to
accept a check box
id parameter
and now we're going to return
what we find here and so we'll get
element by id
and let's just go ahead and select
the check box with the id and then we
can say
next element sibling
so that is the element right beside it
that's what we're doing the very next
element and that is the label that we
need
and then we can grab that text content
from the label
we'll save that and now that should work
to grab
the label text and save it in remove
text
and you know what i want to put the
update persistent data
above that just so we have these two
lines together that we created
and now when we remove an item by
checking the box it should once again
update that paragraph in that paragraph
with the screen reader we'll say removed
from list
so we could say tacos removed from list
or tacos added
and those are the action verbs that we
have got to pass quick fix here i
discovered one error i put a colon
instead of a semicolon after this line
we've got to fix that
and now we're ready to try out our
additions to our web app
okay let's try out the new additions to
the web app especially for the screen
reader
to-do list tab
and let's add taco t c
o s tacos added
yes that's what we wanted now let's add
salsa
a salsa added excellent add new item to
list
section to-do list
we wanted to we wanted to announce the
to-do list instead of going straight to
the clear button
remove all items from the list button
check box not checked code
check box not checked tacos
check box not checked salsa
check box not checked salsa room
edit text section well it almost got
removed out
that's added new item section
check box not checked checked
eat remove from list enter a new to do
item with hint add item
and there you have it our to-do list web
app project with
html5 css3 that
is compiled from sas and javascript
and we made it mobile first and
responsive for all sizes of viewports
we made it accessible and therefore we
can use the app
just with a keyboard or we can even use
it with the screen reader if necessary
and then we used persistent data so we
could close out of the app and come back
to it whenever we want to
and still have our to-do list items of
course this app still has a lot of room
for improvement and i'm sure you can
make your own please leave comments
and let me know what you're going to do
to improve the app
thanks for watching